d'aussi loin qu'il se souvienne robes à
la chaux 27 ans a toujours rêvé d'être
ici au milieu de ces animaux mais
aujourd'hui sa vocation d'éleveurs et
qu'on produit vos problèmes de charge de
traçabilité de contraintes
environnementales et il faut que ben on
passe bientôt autant de temps revient à
remplir des papiers qui avaient eu à
travailler et à rester avec nos animaux
et qui nous plaisent beaucoup
aujourd'hui l'agriculteur soutient la
mobilisation des professionnels du
secteur le 3 septembre prochain
et c'est aussi le cas de ses confrères
réunis à sully-sur-loire à l'occasion de
la fête des bestiaux comme ce producteur
de la vallée dans le guide aulas qui à
la ferme c'est soit on va le mettre dans
une grosse cuve pour le réfrigérer et
après le laitier va venir
d'après ben on va le mettre dans des
briques ou dans des bouteilles alors
c'est bon on se lève tous les jours pour
perdre de l'argent quand on se lève le
matin il ya des fois on se dit mais
pourquoi on part travailler pris à la
gorge les agriculteurs demandent des
prix rentable des charges allégées et
des normes moins contraignante il juge
le plan d'urgence annoncé par le
gouvernement insuffisant et c'est pour
cela qu'ils soutiennent la mobilisation
la manifestation est fait pour me
réveiller un peu les pouvoirs publics
parce qu'apparemment ils ne comprennent
pas que peuple à l'agriculture de nos
régions convient d'élevage va
disparaître le 3 septembre
ils se rendront à paris en tracteur la
fédération nationale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles a prévu un
milliers d'engins dans la capitale